first of all his hair has never looked
like ever in his life when he was born
he wasn't born with that look every
Jennifer yeah like you should be in
Glendale my friend no that is a
summertime picture right there
I mean and your head you look the ashpit
see like your space is so thin bro
they look like you've been on the keto
for a long time oh my god yeah I look
pretty like cuz his head looks way
bigger than yours
yeah what happens is the minute you
retire you get wounded or you you talk
you have your point of view yeah and
you're not happy with the way it went or
you lost Fran's neck yeah I'll take it
you want to know what happened yeah and
it's really interesting
I bet anything with firefighters like
Walter in it you know and then it
doesn't go their way and like man and
all the like darkness even if it does
all you're like these guys go your way
there there are always problems I mean
it's rare what do you mean if because if
it goes well like I bet you don't hear a
peep from Connor you don't hit anything
you still hear about the [ __ ] and
Ronda you still hear about the medal you
guys have a money name one go well
that's ridiculous so they were saying
just give me any but your your example
isn't doesn't really hold water because
I can't let anyone out of the UC roster
go what I'm saying is that there are
problems when you're a fighter in the
UFC three people make money whatever it
is okay more than that whatever the case
I'm just saying that just because you
made money doesn't mean you don't have
problems
oh yeah sure I'm saying that nonsense
yeah well what happens is you'll get on
and they go back but you'll get a
journalist who looks at what happened
and you go what's going on in the Middle
East and then they go through they just
go through all of the how difficult that
is to do anything yeah and then you're
left with this large question I'm going
what can the United States do when they
go into a country are you really trying
to change that country because you can't
know like it's really interesting you
can bomb the [ __ ] out of people and
somehow if if they don't have
money and they don't have young men
don't have something to do with
themselves you're always gonna have
what's called Taliban you can name the
one you want it's just a bunch of dudes
young kids who go whether you go to them
hey listen I'll give you a weapon a
reputation you're something to do and
and a group of PETA and you know here's
this but that's what by the way we have
that here in their gangs that's until
you have disenfranchised kids who have
no chance to make any money anywhere
else and they don't put on drugs and
they may not have had good good parents
or a father figure or mother figure so
they're looking for somebody to grab
them under their wing and go hey you're
with us you're part of us you just got
to do this but a lot of time like you
like especially with NFL guys who played
for like 10 12 years and then 10 years
go by and they want to sue the NFL to
them right yeah yeah or the UFC fighter
who want who's gets on Twitter and
starts shouting at Dana White's like
homeboy you knew it Jane
yeah what'd you think was gonna happen
yeah well you were they supposed take
care of everybody when you're done but
also like LA so most help most boxers
were approached don't make money right
would you say most boxers who are pros
don't make money right most boxers like
the guys in the undercard the but no you
know I'm saying the game did that but
they know this but do any of these to
get to Floyd Mayweather but that's what
they signed up for what percentage of
those people who are professional say
UFC what percentage of people who are
considered professional fighters would
you say make a good living 5% that's it
that's and do the other 95 acting was
acting any different I mean will stand
up nice but stay lives the same wing but
less than 1% we have and we have no we
have no net we don't have like I'm not
man or benefits we don't have you
nothing like that anything else but now
do the UFC guys two out of that 5% do or
do chunk of them make money do line make
money though yeah I guess that depends
on like earning like I would say
majority of them are there fighting for
a living like I know a check to pay
check yo yeah with roommates guys you'd
know so I know by the way that's what I
did a deep dive a wife is a bodybuilding
no I mean it's not it's you know it's
like that's that's like a job like if ya
if your job if you work for ups and your
job
oh boy like I talked to him candidly
before all before he became like even
like three years ago he wasn't making
much money you know you had to find me
much money 8080 or whatever other six
you gotta fight it's fighting five times
a year and then he has monsters Cowboys
making money yeah how does making my how
much if you make 164 fight how much of
that goes out to your people your can
10% goes your management so you know and
you're paying for the camp though right
up on for the kid what about what would
you can't cost you I don't know 30 grand
no not that much 15 how long's camp most
guys do 6 to 8 weeks and your manager
gets what 10 percent Tim says and how
many people in the category I mean like
somebody yeah okay oh no nope you got a
pit well that's that's Camp cost okay
your manager would be like Lex would get
10% my fight stuff cuz he negotiated the
contract they really don't need them
these days all managers Fork is the FCC
they don't really play that so now it's
like you just need a manager or an agent
to get you sponsor you you'll do what
they tell you you'll take the fight they
tell you to take right correct yes
what percentage of those guys like what
percentage of their money comes from
sponsorships are outside now not many
did when when Nate was at my house Nate
who Marquart and this is Lenny yeah he
he got a call from me from his little
Joe Silva and just said you're fighting
and they said I can't make that weight
right now and he goes well cut you and
he was like what was your fight he goes
and yet it was like a crisis and I was
like I'll just cut you you're one of the
best what the [ __ ] are they talking
fight business dude [ __ ] that's not
right
imagine think it is right they'll be
again good but this like game you signed
up for I don't like when people cry
about that's the game you sign up well
it's like you four quarterbacks like hey
do any get you in and you're searching
like dude I wouldn't [ __ ] it I'm not
peeking
I was planning on going out longer if
you just create we
before we can move on we can't used you
yeah that's the game yeah you imagine I
mean the if they yeah some of those
rules were me hardiest about it
I was never because I was pissed about
Reebok history come alive
I was never pissed about math like I
knew the game and you just accepted what
are you gonna do those fighters don't
care I mean they're fighters man if they
have those kind of rules in comedy well
there are there are those rules and
nobody gives a [ __ ] about you in comedy
non you make people laugh yeah and and
it's up to you to get people that will
do and go to pray up bomb every night
and see if they have you back yeah or
did that happen to somebody in this room
if you don't do well oh yeah I don't
perform yeah well if you don't know I'll
take it for you you can come everywhere
you can also do well but if you don't
sell take it yes that's it yeah it
doesn't matter sell tickets that's it
because we're not gonna have you back
yeah I got a P never never O'Brien you
also got a gift oh yeah is her for you
he said he made it because your [ __ ] is
your fruity mind oh yeah you're mine
those would be tough Ritu weird those
are sick though yeah okay miss Donny we
had cats cats are sick how long you been
in this studio then chin bottom to to
use how long we'd be there Jen I don't
know time I'll really be able to see
maybe a year and a half I think yeah
Emma - yeah I think I did Nick
Turturro's like in that yeah yeah yep
he's over there well they like that ones
like a row team they're just use it for
different shows Nick's great bill yeah
they get your [ __ ] poster up out
front
no yes where you are yeah you know yeah
no no no rotating thing I'm shota my
below the belts next door right when you
walk is that right yeah so did you
basically rent this place out yeah me
and Malcolm sports so show time and
mouth tour like we need you to be at one
space can have you bounce all around and
at the time that Ike where do you live
I'm like Santa Monica like we're gonna
find you a place to Santa Monica oh and
now you don't live in Santa Monica I
don't live in Santa much you know
Oh Oh that is uh Santa Monica I don't I
don't mind it I love driving man
well um when you have like a clear day
do you have a car to drive on a clear I
Drive that gt2 RS every day every day
every day every day drive race car every
day do you fit in that [ __ ] oh yeah
that's podcast all right you guys ready
or what we've been a deliberate morning
yeah Oh we'll keep everything in if you
as well oh sorry
way too much even on the mic yeah you
where you are
did we say anything like I feel like we
said something nah nothing all right
hey man I got some shoes yeah I don't
know I didn't see the red light dope
major is a little ice cream cone thank
this guy for making me shoes I probably
am I can't wear but I good news is is
that they well sweet the good news is is
that they add like two inches to your
height well that's true and that's a
super company so now I'm gonna be six
four
yeah 6 4 is right yeah I mean you yep
100% I think you're gonna be able to
jump even higher in those two think so
dude yeah I got ups you know this right
have you what are the chances that you
could dunk a tennis ball no I can't III
once so I could grab the rim for a while
yeah well you know but I had to practice
at it and that's it I have short arms
and legs I have a long torso Josh we've
been doing this the quarantine man um
I've been honestly doing a lot of weed
smoking I've been doing a lot of writing
and mushrooms every Monday night okay
everybody's doing drugs have you put on
the quarantine tent you know I really
tried man I've been trying real hard but
you can't [ __ ] with this I just you're
on a better body than Brian it's
imperfect
oh there's no doubt I mean look I don't
wanna I don't wanna do you I don't cut
dude I don't want to put you on the spot
dude but if there's a calendar you're
not on it I don't think so man Black
History Month February I can't
what are you eating how are you eating
honestly putting on weight I've been
eating even cleaner like so give me an
example no dairy
definitely no days I think when I drink
that this raw milk I don't do day I
didn't grow milk yeah yeah baby grasp a
baby sucking it right at the tea
yeah no anybody else who drinks milk I
thought it was good for you yeah baby
raw my son was drinking it tasted good
so I drank the [ __ ] what is that so it
comes right out of the cow into a cup of
milk it's [ __ ] doing what does that
mean it's like say it's artisan sandwich
tastes a milkshake that means our sugar
gonna be yeah and here's what I do I
have the sugar per cup apparently I
don't think milk has the kind of sugar
when it's raw like that it's it's got
lactase right which is a black black
David are you lactose but you but you
chaste I think it's different kind of
sugar about but but you Ted but but like
your girls even natural sugar is sugar
yeah yeah if so if you're I mean orange
isn't a cup of raw milk raw yeah listen
what what the font like not pastor I not
I don't know anyone who drinks milk over
the age of four
yeah first I've heard a drinking man you
do you just drink a glass of raw milk
was just recently twelve grams of sugar
bread and 1244 get oh yeah yeah sugar a
ton sugar melt
yeah tons of sugar that's why so sweet
yes but but but but no I'm putting on
some weight well how much about how much
it's not just that Papa you know this
how much milk are you drinking like
three glasses a day yeah that's nice
time bar the loaded but you also said
you're eating cheese and a lot of cheese
and wine and all that [ __ ] I'm an
[ __ ] yeah that's it all that I got to
stop I'll tell you what I almost feel
better when I smoke weed because I
prepare my food ahead of tart so you
don't get the munchies yeah so I I know
exactly your diet I I might have to
you're going he's genetically gifted I
wake up I have a [ __ ]
that is a plant-based but with protein
and all that other [ __ ] your mate you're
alright you're already annoying me a
little I don't like how loose your mouth
is I don't like how you're going like
yes I've already pissed off a little bit
of a leash because you drink though okay
really annoying
yeah I'll sip on no cuz like yeah
alright he's gone - I know Bobbie so we
got I got a shake you look and tighten
your mouth up when you talk about [ __ ]
it tighten up you're being a little
condescending let me see yeah but you
you start off with the malt milk and
cheese yeah you're right how you gonna
you're like I don't know why I'm getting
away but I'm not anymore because I
didn't put it in my coffee I'm just
using the llama milk in my coffee yeah
in your coffee do I know I was
oh is it go time yeah so is that what's
causing the float it's not good yeah all
right oh yeah hitting your pants ooh
yeah four times a day in the pants no
please just doesn't it runs right
through me mad at the fact that
yesterday I ate this place really good
place but it's an intern Asian
restaurant well they put peppers in
everything peppers are good for you yeah
but my I got a I got a poof four top
separate dude yeah hot peppers - I'm I
wake up my buttholes corn we gotta go
down [ __ ] but so you have a combination
of dairy hot pepper shits yeah all
things bad huh well you what you are you
exercising yeah man I'm doing it twice a
day see all right yeah man well he's
like yes court but I'm saying when
people go do you work yeah yeah yeah
yeah now okay so you've got the
plant-based shake you know you owe him
his wife for joining the thick boys bike
club mm-hmm oh you are she bought bikes
she saw videos aren't you aren't thick
boys so I don't know your movements in
the heart dude actually you know what I
think
thickness in your heart harder you sure
like it now that raw milk is giving you
thickness a heart I'll tell you this
though yeah he was hitting me and Rogin
with you I saw three snakes today and I
gave I gave my rendering in riot act I
go you're full of [ __ ] cuz you're a
nature liar
yeah you didn't see anything but then he
sent me that picture I went every day
dude seeing big guys yeah but it's like
how many how many snakes and I post
every I saw no one today I'm like wow
after a while if you like a job we got
it the second snakes but but I actually
I am the the exact kind of [ __ ] if I
saw one of those snakes I'd be like I'm
not riding up here every well going if
I'm cruising I don't give a [ __ ] I'll
run over one but if I'm if I'm going
slow I don't have my headphones anymore
cuz I'm gonna be able to hopefully I can
hear oh if I'm gonna slow it's game over
you know cuz my text my brother goes
meny be careful cuz I think bite you
where you're at can be tough to get to
get you to the doctor
ya know prayer house like man I wonder
if if I I feel like that my size but bit
me I like the calf maybe I would be
alright I think saying because you're a
big dude snakebite I feel like like if a
big cap yeah
opposed to me yeah I would be able to
maybe get down the head the only yeah it
was your heart you petered out your
heart's beating fast yeah first thing
they say with it without with a
rattlesnake bite is you lie down so that
your heart told let me do that oh the
but if the Bloods pumping the venom goes
through your body faster the heart yeah
I bite you more than once you're nice um
how many people die from rattlesnake
bites in in a year you know when I think
I have some time dude and I calculate
from where I'm at
it takes about thirty five minutes get
downhill if I'm [ __ ] flying now add
in the chaos which in bit by a
rattlesnake Adrenaline's pumping yeah
yeah he asked you a question for me ask
you a question Brendon venomous snake
bite how are you under pressure in
general pretty good are you
I did only five me never been bit by a
rattlesnake but like I'll look out of
8,000 hey it's like Corona out of 8,000
only five people died most fatal bite
sorry - the eastern diamondback
rattlesnake and the western western
that's what I'm [ __ ] but you that you
the Diamond Head one shooter bring up
that thick snake I posted you Terry so
there's a fatal five people have 8000 no
five people you know but the dog is fine
I know it's like Corona any weight a
mask you [ __ ] look there it is that's a
huge snake but that looks like it's
already got something in its body that's
what she's saying that all the snakes up
oh so it's pregnant it's not man it's a
fat [ __ ] snake yeah that's a better
rattle yeah rattle right but you know
they're not rattling as much anymore you
know they're evolving there's a knob
they're not rattling cuz they know if
when they rattle people know where that
I mean they don't know so they're not
Attalus much whoa you know what's now
they say that that big Viper one that I
saw there are nothing he's playing the
[ __ ] Mirage
do you know one of my favorite practical
jokes I went to sometime I hate golfing
so when I do golf in California I bring
up Morocco with me and I always because
there's rattlesnakes on courses and so
when I go with people I'll always say
once or twice a be careful guys are
snakes and so when we go into the woods
and look for their ball I'll sneak up
next and we just rattle them her snake
gets on the path we're going pretty fast
and I was like it's kind of just
chilling there it started going but then
just stopped and so I saw people coming
like you know I'm a good citizen so I
was like snake snake guys right cool all
thanks bro Thanks Oh old lady I see her
everyday she runs the same time shredded
older she just goes has her headphones
in and I go ma'am choke Tanis [ __ ]
purple skin I know ma'am ma'am there's
snake that she goes what I know
rattlesnake be careful she's like okay
and just [ __ ] get it very off ran it
right didn't give a [ __ ] dude
yeah wrench straight path right yeah but
I think when you hit a certain age like
my dad right now he goes out every day
and i'm like daren't you worried he's
like i'm 82 that's like people with I
mean yeah 82 what what this is that's a
bill with sharks that got like Jeff's
son yeah he's like they saw a great
white and they everybody had to get out
of water he waited till the [ __ ]
waited in that life cars left news went
right back in
have you guys had with this what are you
gonna do stop mountain biking I love it
no you'll do it have you guys had Paul
de Gelder on the show yeah so have we
he was a guy who lost his arm and leg oh
[ __ ] yeah hell yeah
did you so a long time ago I had him on
my Shark Week show great guy great guy
did you have you seen the video of him
getting bitten by the shot eaten by the
shark
no so I wasn't video there is a video I
really no calluses so there is a hundred
percent of video it's like I thought he
was maybe he was and it was during there
I think you can pull it up all you can
see is like it's like a shadowy cuz it
was shot at night alright and so he was
due I watched the video with him let's
see if this is it and he I asked him I
go does that bother you to watch that
video and he's like nah it almost seems
like a different person different life
but when you hear him talk about giving
up like being underwater and being like
this is how it's gonna happen it was the
there it is I thought this was like a
really stays no that was him in his he
was in Sydney Bank yes yeah and he was
basically from what I understand that
the Australian equivalent of a Navy SEAL
right that's him well that's him -
that's him getting thrashed around and
it was a tiger shark right bull shark
that's him and that's him starting to
swim back to the boat and does it did it
and it did all that damage they did all
that damage
yeah but late am i didn't realize it
they had that [ __ ] on yeah at some point
man because that's what I'm asking you
how are you under pressure at some point
I'd have just been like this is it for
me like I'm not swimming to a boat what
he died in the boat yes yeah and he told
you how they his friends kept him alive
by literally beating the [ __ ] out of him
but he said when he started to swim back
and he put he tried to put his arm over
his head yes when I'm you imagine no
[ __ ] like oh my god we went to punch
the shark yeah the shark was like you
kind of push me underwater yeah but when
I went so I went swimming with sharks
have you guys done that yes I actually
I held on to the fin you show me the
shark though it was a it's a lemon shark
his big goes like lemons it was like
what was yours makeup we went with Mako
that's a little more date it's like a
little that's the meth shirt walk around
make it makes so we went because I did
that Shark Week show and you're I
auditioned for that you beat me out all
I actually saw you at the audition when
I was walking in he was walking out but
the guy told me gnarly he said he said
the shark comes up and bumps you it's
gonna bump you once to kind of test you
and to see if your food if it comes up
to try to bump you again don't let it
push it away by its nose and I said hey
man but the nose is right near the
[ __ ] mouth yeah and he was like yeah
make sure you get the nose but but but
sharp it's noses how long ago was that
shark show yeah probably 2015 I just saw
like somewhere it was bananas they threw
me in because I don't know how to swim
but they wanted to know how to swim too
old I not a swim but I don't know how to
swim an ace in a scuba with the snorkel
I know how to swim but I've never star
club before and they threw me in the
water in a with a snorkel because they
needed to get it for shot and I didn't
know they tie to weight around your
waist I just went I just didn't say it's
a good thing that had me attached to a
rope because they the naturally
assaulting me back up but it's really
don't [ __ ] with people the Makos I don't
hear a lot of make go down there just
quick they don't around yeah yeah they
get eaten by other sharks too apparently
but man the is that real I don't think
can't be uh it might be a maybe do you
know the scariest thing those guys told
me in that show is because I was like
well I mean you know I'm here I'm not
really scared and one guy said are you
you have you ever gotten in the water in
Santa Monica I said yeah and he said up
to your waist and I said yeah and he
said well you've been within four feet
of a shark
yeah great whites - yeah and I said no
way and he goes yeah Santa Monica for
sure you just can't see him cuz that
water so [ __ ] dirty they're all out
there oh yeah I remember this right yeah
Holly ball and and he looking exactly
like a seal by the way
it's been scams besides he says east as
he's flipping his body over his smooth
Co like bodies he's like my bro you got
to stop with the ceiling person yeah
yeah you're in waves and and where he
couldn't stand in the water he wanted
one and by the way had a shaved head so
he wasn't so he looked like a [ __ ]
seal just one with the water on yeah
you're not not seal sigh and you're
delicious yes I mean there's a lot of
wonderful meat on your old on your old
like in the like right right there right
where your ribs are they would love to
take a little bit ago I fall shark
problems you might not go and you just
get all OH
jacked up what's the worst way to go as
far as an animal attack Oh crocodile
beer bear better seen bear seems small
cuz it'll drag you around first dude
what bear bears don't ask you gotta eat
your legs and everything they starting
would start eating right is your free
see you've seen revenant yeah no they do
that they eat the ass video don't eat
aspirin I'll start eating your legs what
happens like people turn over and they
covered up and this is what I was going
for anyway where they grab you by the
legs as you're punching them and they're
like really a big grizzly bear polar
bear be by far the worst thing angry
it's not quick no there's in the walls
in the cats get you by the neck and kill
you die yeah that'd be the best bride be
terrifying alligator would suck to to be
twirled like that rag down I'll use that
well especially if there's more because
you ever see just one alligator chilling
now it's you see him in the homies yeah
so all the homies run a train on you
it's all water crocodile if you watch
watch what a saltwater crocodile
here's we're good just put up when a
saltwater crocodile is coming at you but
man gets attacked by crime you have
these you have these know you have these
these gazelles there's a gazelle that's
swimming yeah yeah he tries to make it
and watch watch the wake that the 2,000
pound crocodile these are coming out
watch the wake and that that would be
horrifying
that's one first No
yeah go to that okay those are no these
are National Geographic that the yeah
but this is that real [ __ ]
this is Costa Rica this is where we were
at yeah that was slapping the show yeah
you were what it's a dinosaur but that's
the thing like the reason they're per
their perfect anyone daring
dinosaurs oh yes he could see but he see
he's feeding it he's not from Costa Rica
he's just a white dude who got some
chicken I think you man give it the
chicken bronze look how close give it
the chicken brah you [ __ ] dummy
yeah they slap the meat to get them
going they're very shy what yeah sure
the Christ Jerry crocodile Pat's calling
camera well why is it that looks a bit
like the one with the watering hole with
the craw crabs that got the elephant I
don't set out with the office in trunk
yeah they'll fit died down in the road
yeah how big how big her these crocs
Brian oh I don't know 20 feet dude
I'm not joking what's this J this might
be an advocate video this might be a
delay this is where in Australia where
the [ __ ] one t feet you swim with a
salty once I swim in a salty once yeah
so for me I think that may be the worst
way to go actually you know monkeys rip
your face off yeah that seems with
chimpanzees
Jonesy's the shahbazi say say the French
me know it [ __ ] there's no official
video just I'm talking about it yeah I
bet you any video that shows the
crocodile eating an actual person may
not live too long do you know my son
when he came home from Afghanistan he is
he back for a good night he finished
yeah he's been all four years he's been
here before yeah but yeah and um he came
back and we threw him a party right and
so he said hey can I show a slide show
at the party and I go yeah you guys I
want to show you my friends and it's
cool I said okay cool alright we're
gonna put it on the super old-school
yeah but yeah slide show us and it was
on the iPhone just probably not like a
[ __ ] yeah right yeah no like it's on
Oh dad you love this this is my friend
Eddie that's us in the desert slick
oh there's my friend Frank also in the
desert he said irori father you go over
like how old is he
yeah um buggy he said to me I go but
about 15 minutes for the party I go
ahead man throw it on the computer let
me just see it real quick just I want to
know where to put it because there are
people ages 6 to 80 at this so he shows
it to me the first ones are picture him
and his friends getting off the plane
and you come into the get into their
there their bunks and where there is
staying and out on patrol and [ __ ] and
then there's just this video tell me
it's him like this since Isis head dude
there's a video of a dry riverbed and
Afghani men walking down by the dry
riverbed and then a carpet bomb and then
no more people and I go hey man
I can't show this at the party no and he
goes why not there's no blood I go but
that's actual death right and he was
yeah but no blood I go yeah no no it
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't matter did
he come back kind of kind of you know a
little more hard yes my gesture hims not
a big deal now it it changes you know
for me man the biggest thing for me okay
is he dead behind the eyes now no not
quite but he has seen some [ __ ] that I
like I I one of my favorite things to do
to my kids is scare him I've always
scared my kids so he had been back for
maybe two months and one of the best
scares is a car horn cuz a car horn
makes you think I'm about to be hit by a
car unless your son has PTSD sure
completely forgot I honked the horn he
grabbed for where his gun used to be and
then he just looked at me he goes don't
[ __ ] do that and I was like right how
old is he my fault man completely my
fault 27 he's gonna for a long time
what's that been there he's been there a
long time he's no he's back he's back
yeah yeah you know well naturally but
that he's at she saw action yeah yeah
the big the biggest problem is now what
they're finding is that for the first
time in the history of warfare and so in
the United States we've had these guys
thank you seriously no my feet are my
feet but but they've had this for the
first time men are being rotated to talk
about man
yes that's about Warby yes guys I wore
these I wore these in the war oh yeah
there's a [ __ ] to keep them really why
yeah but guys who are like these did tip
of the spear guys who were doing like
10,000 people really fighting this war
for the past 17 years well more than
that before that but now we had these
guys these guys on rotation so often
like these SEAL Teams and they're
they're constantly going back into the
theater back in the theater it's so bad
for them I mean when you're doing that
for 10 years it that's what they like
those no it's it but it usually what
would be is you would retire them they
would go they do it tours
three things then they go and be
instructor uh-huh problem with the
problem with that sort of constant
combat over that constant cop out of
constantly going back is is what it does
to them and it's not pretty but but I
bet if you ask the Special Forces guys
they want to stay so so he said my buddy
said that he said if you tried to get
them to stop doing that it'd be a mutiny
that's why I think for their own good
and for anybody's good you you rotate
those guys out you can't have dudes in
the theater for the best though well but
there's no way there's no way they're
gonna ever gonna find anything here that
matches that the bigger that's well
that's why our friend [ __ ] and he's
not jumps off a [ __ ] yeah giant
mountains in a squirrel well sorry for
the Andy Andy son Eddie stuff yeah yes
so he's got he's great too he's staying
with me right now yeah yeah and he has a
podcast called cleared hot and he
interviewed a guy named Mike Glover a
Mike is a CIA paramilitary guy who was a
contractor went green beret and then
went on doing stuff they had a they had
a fast things the last podcast they had
one of those fascinating conversations
I've ever heard especially about a
minute I'm an hour thirty it's a long
podcast huh but the [ __ ] guy started
talking me he said something I've never
heard anybody say he goes I'll be honest
with you I'd love to say like a lot of
guys say well it's hard to say bye to my
family and stuff
the problem with war when you're in
combat is nothing focuses your mind like
that and nothing gets you in a flow like
that at all
like when it's life and death and then
when you start getting
good at that he said the truth is most
of us can't wait to get back on that
truck can't wait to get back into the
theater and that's when you now now
you're dealing with a liability you're
dealing with you have to deal with that
that's something to contend my son
wanted to go back yeah that [ __ ] he
ended up going back and I was just like
man you know he and I was asking but
what about this and this he wasn't yeah
he's like it just doesn't nothing is the
same as being there and I felt you felt
guilty not being there oh yeah that
makes sense that's the other you get he
did they're both an Ian and Mike Glover
said it's not about hatred it's about
love yeah you [ __ ] fall in love with
you share this fraternity which is such
a rare thing to grow up with I grow with
he was a special guy special ops Kai
with her and he was CIA or something
like that I don't know what the [ __ ] he
did but he said he was right next to
these these the tip of the spear guys
they big combat action group the Delta
guys and they were all pissed off at one
point like back in I don't know when I
was there like something about that when
when Don't Ask Don't Tell came in and
gays in the military and some of them
were like I got [ __ ] I don't want to
serve these guys and then my buddy was
like you guys [ __ ] couldn't be each
other which others know while you do
pull-ups you shave your forearms if you
guys could dye your hair you would and
have that Trojan callsign there
what I want to do now ah no no you know
he I think Blackwater
he might get met boarded out I think
he's getting met boarded out of the army
he's got some back issues that he just
can't shake and I don't I think and so
he's looking for whatever he's gonna do
but he said the same thing he was like I
don't know what I'm gonna do pay for his
college and stuff no right yeah I don't
know exactly what all they will take
care of for them but harnesses for them
to transition the heart yes how what do
you do now cuz you're like one of the
other things they were saying like
Glover and stuff your life is actually
super simple because we're finishing its
missions and and and structured no yes
dude up bills he even said that Michael
ever said I don't have to emotionally
take care of my wife I don't have to him
I don't have to worry about bills I
don't have to worry about that single my
purpose I'm not comparing anything to
warm I'm an electronics but when when
they get done you know whether it's
military or football ball basketball
hockey UFC fighters there's a transition
period for everybody for everybody yes
well for firfer the one difference also
with athletes is they have something
that's a little different not any harder
but as an athlete in this country
especially if you're an elite athlete
you've been told you're Superman your
whole life and then one day you're not
yeah
one day nobody gives a [ __ ] who you are
your entire existence people have been
sucking your dick because of what you
can do and then one day nobody gives a
[ __ ] you sent me that article on
football players and how regimented your
[ __ ] life is you know when you're
playing in the NFL and then it just goes
away overnight yeah and now you guys get
depression then they blame on CT it's
like now dude I've never found anything
yeah your depression came from me not
finding another passion don't blame it
on brain trauma home all right came from
you never got your foot in the in
society are you are you guys like are
you guys more productive when you have
all this free time or less we've been
doing fought three podcasts a week and
I'm love I do five podcasts a week oh so
you you see four for most people this
free time is terrible for them I've been
writing you need that structure and that
like I like the structure I like you
need it
like doing the podcast in the morning
and then doing stand-up at night yup and
going on the road Thursday Friday
Saturday then Sundays I get to rest
I miss the road I love I miss I like
that I like that routine I miss stand-up
so badly
I've done a couple of the stand-ups like
afferent offices and they leave some of
the microphones open so you can hear
laughter and and you can see them and I
got to tell you man
it was so much better than I thought it
was going to be kind of an oddity
it's in front of an audience it's just
like a giant zoom with hundreds of
people and so some people mute their
mics because they have a loud house and
some people are by themselves so you can
just hear them laughing and so you hear
the crowd it's cool it man I got to tell
you I have been I had written probably
20 minutes of just like the corona stuff
and it just felt good to get up to try
it out do you know what I really found
out the most about stand-up since this
time is stand-up creatively fuels the
rest of my creativity oh yeah stand-up
is the engine that drives everything
else and when I don't have that I'm not
as good creatively in the other areas
there's no that's fun either yeah every
baggy yeah
have you but you've been doing your show
on Monday nights right or Monday days I
do man I've been doing that controlled
chaos show I'm actually poised on we had
the insane be in sync on I got Luke
Bryan on on Friday Luke Bryan is your
podcast it's a my yeah I do like a it's
like a comedy game show on Tuesdays
Bryan Luke Bryan's on American Idol
yeah he's unheard of him he's not on
Friday man and it way the guests have
been out of control last night we had
Instagram Jim he'd sure have had the
Backstreet Boys on it was the insane
let's see Matt make out Justin without
justice I get crazy but let me tell you
something so Joey Fatone said one of the
funniest things man I wish I had similar
I had Jeremiah you and Joey kind of
looked as though I had Jeremiah and
personating Justin and he came on and he
was like hey guys I want you to write a
song with me and Joey was like I know
this isn't the real Justin because that
guy would never let us write a song
yeah yeah they're on tomorrow Josh
Justin also said hold my talent and we
don't make all the money yeah yeah yeah
tomorrow night he's on with his wife she
is hilarious do you guys know who
chelsea lynn is i don't she does this
character yeah yeah the real here is
that a you know that's all that's not
she's hilarious
yeah yeah she she's a bike should be
part of the food boys bike man
you know what we should get her part of
that thick board I like she is on top of
that she's division Oh me neither
I like a big confident girl man she's
super confident man well you'd have to
be my friend especially with a I have a
buddy you know there is this girl is
giant she's a giant mm-hmm she's a giant
watch in what what do you mean she's a
giant like tall yeah no she's also 300
pounds but she's also it's all it's it's
not fat she's a giant no well like like
it literal merican woman she's a
beautiful woman but she's I swear to god
she's new dog right there that's where
he's six five she's six six and she's
maybe even taller
did she ever play sports nope and she's
this big will you just end my friend cuz
hey and he's kind of a big guy and kind
of heavy and they were they were like
hugging and I was like this and he goes
like this she's [ __ ] here she goes I
go oh my god are you [ __ ] are you ten
years old what does that mean I don't
think she enjoyed he was all like down
my buddies all [ __ ] kind of heavy
into and it was like I was like that
just is who think he was kind of shorter
than she was I was just like you're
going to hands if she has told him
backstage names and I was like she's got
her tits yeah go hot I hired a woman
that size to beat my friend up at his
bachelor party she's the [ __ ] oh my god
guys I wouldn't like that at all no he
thought I was high he thought I was
getting a stripper and so he was
blindfolded and when I took off his
blindfold there was this woman who was
about six foot she probably went about
370 standing right in front of him naked
and he was just he he looked at me and
looked at her and all he said out loud
before she grabbed him was why and she
just grabbed and boom yanked him out of
his chair he was like he's like five six
140 oh so he can't even put up a fight
no she [ __ ] with him is he is he that
weighs in - no no no not at all no it
was his bachelor party he's hired he
picked the wrong person I told him I go
man you don't want me to do this you
know how much I like to [ __ ] with people
hire somebody do you remember the big
black girl from Beacher's Madhouse
yes yeah I know you're talking about
she's living her uh she's already she's
pretty she's a amia well she's a large
woman it's positive Wednesday apparently
she I see around Venice she's a very you
what I mean is she's really a very nice
person I really like a very nice person
yes that's her how about you should yeah
yeah she's a well I actually think she
is there for sure yeah and she's yours
she is pretty how does your own look
that big she's a tall posture than Brad
I mean clothes yeah really
she's just be six six yeah she's only
giant weight but I mean the biggest
cities in the world really because she'd
next to be a beach or muscle lost a lot
of weight is Beecher still is that still
open I should go there every Friday
night first
la with my friends you did every Friday
I loved that place did you want to go to
my stands here I know you did
oh there she is that's a big whoa
wow that's a big guy okay you have seen
her I've seen her and she's a nice she's
a she's a sweet really sweet
yeah I've talking away to like that wait
she's bigger than you well you know and
ease and ease I have my hands full
what's the biggest woman you've ever
come across to that dude I don't I'm not
a bee yeah I don't know you have you
ever been with a woman who's tipping 200
no no I've been with me - I have my dick
goes Nidal thinks ahead I've been with a
a couple when I was younger there was a
girl who was just a big girl I'd always
wanted to have sex you don't know Carter
is urchin yeah oh I had always wanted to
have sex with a woman who looked like
Nell Carter all right can you bring up
Nell Carter yeah yeah so this had always
been on my list I always wanted to have
yeah he's into that but yeah man oh I
saw there was this woman I was
bartending right so those are nails yeah
that's not her
I was I was bartending one night and
there was a woman sitting at the end of
the bar and she had been there all night
by herself and I asked her at the tours
and then I go what he's doing she was
like I stood up I know and she had been
making me laugh all night this girl no
no no harder but a woman who looked like
Nell Carter and so I said we were
closing down and I always wanted to get
pancakes after work and I go you won't
have pancakes with me she was yeah she
had me make you so we got two pancakes
but laughing the whole time and she was
in the middle dude she had just cut off
the biggest bite that any human being
could put in their mouth and she the
girl puts the fork of Pancakes in her
mouth and looks right at me and starts
to chew and she goes so we [ __ ] her
walk
and I was like yeah yeah who they are
huh it was game on it was game on man I
would tell you it was different you know
when there's so many layers yeah there's
there's different smells that come out
of different you know what I mean
because you're having a man I just like
to sample a little bit of everything
just to see what I don't like it when
I'm right well I've never had my balls
set on fire but I but you do drink we're
all milk so more I don't
by the way Andy's a girl is a strong
woman she's the current world black belt
world champion the jujitsu in the
seniors division and I was like looking
at her and she's sturdy strong and I was
like I'm glad there's a woman in my
house that could kick the [ __ ] out of me
right now that could choke now just beat
me up
she bigger than you small he's she's
little I think she's bigger stronger
than I am
yeah she's tall in you she's well that's
not sure she's probably five we'll get
the if you looked up when my senior
world champion yeah how old how old 35
she is 36 to me she's I don't know how
that's math for 35 is seniors well
comments are we a stud she's a [ __ ]
stud she teaches her no it's no it's her
name is I'm sorry her name is Leah
Taylor Leah Taylor yeah and she's a
beast I and she's at your house right
now yeah yeah there she is do you roll
with her - there she is right there oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah she I've asked you
this before and I remember you told me I
asked you once what percentage of the
world do you think you could beat in a
fight and you said like ninety nine
ninety nine point nine something like
that but how is when I see the house
Society extra extra Korona yeah how they
reacted grown about 99
not but Bryan Callen oh damn she's a
baddie
well she's percentage of the what
percentage of the world do you think
they use what percentage of the world do
you think you could beat me $19.99 you
think you're up at night let me let me
put it this way I keep I'll keep a lot
of people busy and with a few with 30%
give you a little credit to 30% already
athletic 30% of the world on already
athletic and I do percent of world
well I still train are you give weight
what percentage of women are you saying
could beat them up because you got a
presented 50% of the world is women
right is that right
no I'm most almost all women is this 90%
women I try I'm no no no I'm not saying
you can beat up I'm saying 50% of the
world are women but I mean yeah so you
could go 99% of women maybe I don't know
a lot of them yeah look at the bottom
line is I'm I'll keep I'll surprise you
and I don't like his [ __ ] that take
it back 35% all right no I I want and no
one in the UFC no females in the UFC ah
Brian I got you at about 68% yeah though
and maybe more than that I'll give you
know I'll give you 60% the way societies
active but I'm pretty athletic
you've seen me [ __ ] roll and about
possible you're 52 53 53 pretty good man
I mean not this but pretty good I'm
pissed off you know he's probably right
but that's still a lot of people I don't
know I still spar spar two days ago I
didn't spar I moved around with a pro
and I got I hit him and he kind of
tapped me around I just watched him yeah
beta modernize for you if you spar with
somebody can say you spray I can't say
it's part with it if you have you pay a
pro to spar with you yeah you know they
want to keep your money of course they
want you to keep also also that by the
way they're not gonna hit me because
they would kit you don't say you've
sparred with pros when you're an actor
you can't say that it's just different
right these oh so what I do is I get hit
a little note you did for round you
moved around gonna sweat on that's right
but no it's not boxing you moving around
the last time I walk then it's a little
naughty back
he's hitting me back he's not hitting
you back tap me up a little bit not real
the last time I sparred I sparred with a
was a sparring today
he's annoying new you while your home
your mouth thing set me on a bed my dad
told me drink milk we on D Vegas D Vegas
argument are you a tight dairy for the
most part yeah you don't do pizza if you
put a slice in front of me as hard I try
it oh dude my brother sent me a link
this morning I should send each in
Printz pizza in New York it's a deep
dish pizza in dry ice frozen sea bean
coli can't be [ __ ] what is it what do
you get when you get that when you go
there he has a pepperoni - sighs
pepperoni it will knock your dick in the
dirt is that the kind of deep dish like
you've had Lou Malnati's in Chicago yeah
[ __ ] okay you know I figured you
know thick it is right you could only
eat like to roll at that point yeah talk
about deep-dish pizza I don't give a
[ __ ] bin slice this is New York deep
that's Chicago casserole I went all the
top you can suck my dick
you know what I used to like they had
theirs on Fairfax was Damiano
did you ever eat damiano's on Fairfax
it's pretty good you can still order all
right the best piece is called my
Holland's pizza here yes where is it
there's there's a Joe's pizza which I
thought was the same one as New York but
there's kind of Felix Felix I might have
some of the Felix might have the best
pizza I've ever had recently Rose cafe
sick and so is Julian
but we this great juice does pizza juice
same hey I'll tell you what felix has
the best [ __ ] pasta i mean pizza
really well where is that place it's in
a bikini so you can order the that one
you like in Chicago can or that loose
you know where that yeah I either I'm
not a deep-dish casserole I went to the
place where uh Al Capone the Valentine's
Day mass you don't have time out yeah I
went to there we waited in an hour
the bread was nice it it was good but
compared to New York I want you to come
have a felix pizza with me I think you'd
really like it you know what I did
yesterday I went to join a takeaway and
I and I had two burrata Pomodoro pizza
and it was it was so crazy hi good
Tigers favorite pizza oh there it is
hundred $24 and get the real [ __ ] said
to you dude I might have to do that and
go straight pepperoni so yeah keep that
roaming and they put that in dry ice dry
ice and it's frozen I'll send it to you
now you don't have the same ovens as the
place let's give me I heard good my mama
did it with lose for Christmas one year
and it was fantastic
wow that looks like when we were doing
that easy this [ __ ] guy I swear to
God would have his mother send him whoo
howls owns our DDM calzones from Jersey
from where he was in Jersey and we were
like and Dave Herman I was like your mom
sent you calzones and he was like this
well [ __ ] mama's boy left about a nice
calzone man ahh
a pizza sandwich I'm not like the pizza
man I can't do the pizzas you take the
calzone a dip it in the sauce you told
me you had some of the Eddy I mean with
Frankie Edgar and Jersey a piece of the
water yeah yeah but that's why you can't
get New York Pete's out here because the
water that's not true anymore
go go have that feel like school have
Jelena go I have Rose cafe they got some
baby perfect this Joe's pizzas and this
Mahone's pizza the Felix pizza
Jelena take away and gusta they'll [ __ ]
with anybody in the world instead of
father Ben what do you want some
what the [ __ ] is that I drink now that's
the role of Japanese whiskey success
whiskey ain't touch and fraud resides
deal
let's um and are you just sipping it out
of a you want a cup yeah it's so nice
because I just read cops cap are you
want one good I'm having are you you're
just drinking it out of the bottle
yeah wait I thought it was like a weird
iced tea and I was like yeah he has a
little problem not a big one yeah in a
night a whole bottle he's sober yeah
he's a whiskey guy and when he's on the
road he's on the road so I was doing the
Friday and Saturday he's going through
two bottles of whiskey you know who I
blame is Joe Rogan I'm Joe Rogan because
it made you stand up when I eat is do
have a shot man do you I don't drink
before I do stand up years have a shot
with me trust me we're doing it long in
your honor are you give me a [ __ ]
shot shot of whiskey best side of my
life went well yeah there you go
yeah and since then him then then I went
from shots to doubles and so I have a
double I have a shot and a double before
every set and then I got on here started
talk about adderall yeah I got about a
thousand I got some dams gone it ruined
my life yeah stay the [ __ ] that's what I
thought literally it rode like it run
that's why some people don't hey don't
listen tell it does [ __ ] with your dick
the reason he said didn't cuz he only
took half a pill okay
cuz if taking full pill I bet but also
at his age life is [ __ ] with his dick
and at our age it kind of not for
nothing not to be not to be a dick about
uh do you know what I do though but at
the Saturday night late shows I'll tell
you 100 milligram of edibles right
before my Saturday night Late Show every
session Joey Diaz [ __ ] if for me it's
just all about fine cheers boys
yes brother [ __ ] I can't remember the
last time I had whiskey really I'm a
tequila gun yas'm this is this is a
beautiful whiskey and it tastes like
that good not extra añejo it's a caramel
so good oh my god that's a smooth dance
Bubba you'll get addicted to this here's
the thing man cuz I can sip tequila all
day long but this stuff always makes me
go this is
smooth that's that's Japanese my eco
what is it what is the name that's a
male but it's Bushido is good male but
Bush ooh that's male Beto Shido
seventeen holy
yeah it's distilled in 2001 gentlemen
doesn't mean anything to me I don't know
I mean it's like my they said this wine
was yeah I don't 2001 we're on lockdown
we're on DEFCON [ __ ] five or
something huh remember that after after
9/11 yeah but you know the difference is
you were young huh how do you do that
we're doing that September 11 yeah I was
a freshman in college at Whittier in
California up here I remember I remember
cuz I woke up early cuz that football
practice and my dad called me go what's
up I know I'm your scared of practice
and he was so mad he's what are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you not watch the news
like in college dude on a [ __ ] yeah
people I know what he was find a TV man
find the TV we're at war that's a gal
Jesus Christ were like he's so you know
right he's right then why he was like it
got it galvanized us like you you said
hello the difference between now and
then is that really brought everybody
you saw on the streets hold the doors
for each other how are you saying alo to
each other came together I will always
like me hate yes but but but like the
problem is is that with anything like
this where that that separates people
when people go and try to find
information they're not truly trying to
find information they're just trying to
find facts that make them feel better
so nobody's really trying to find the
truth they're trying to find what makes
what they want is your the techies
governor today he did know cuz they open
up and he's getting [ __ ] for opening up
they saying I'm just looking at the
facts man I'm going through the facts
does it make sense that were shutting it
down I'm not saying that people have to
open up if they're comfortable they can
open up we're give him the option we're
giving them that's to open I think
giving them the option and then and then
the lady interview me she's like well
what about you know social distant he
goes yeah he goes you go to a grocery
store right we all go to go stores did
you go to go store she goes yeah he goes
then why can't we do that every place
that's house business why can't we take
the same precautions figure it out these
same business places yes open
restaurants let people make their own
choices I
I like all the business and economy
connection I just don't Gavin Newsom is
being very very cautious and it's being
told 15 different things from 15
different sources that's the problem I
yeah and I and I think but I so he's a
Democrat so the economy
it makes Trump look bad if economy you
know anything I would say about that is
that most of the world is still on
lockdown yeah so my question is are they
getting information we are not getting
what what is going on are there like
what this this this virus is strangely
wily we're not sure what it does some
people it [ __ ] people have really badly
other people we know people 50 and under
the chance of them dying er yeah oh my
new yes I think though go back if you're
under 50 get your ass back to [ __ ] but
here's the one thing I think the one
thing that that is true boat well the
other thing that also is true and I've
been delivering food to the people at
Cedar sinai all right all right but it
no no but but I only say that to say
this you can't you can't ignore their
experience you cannot tell everyone's
down to on the front line you can't
right you can't ignore the fact that
they're like it's we're overrun it's not
like first of all they're not overrun
they're not overrun but but or not but
the Possible's are shutting down because
they don't have this but the bigger like
when you're in talking about California
it's not and I would say that New York
is but DVR on top of each other but but
even in New York the hospitals because
we we decided to go on quarantine to
beat the curve right to make sure the
hospitals don't get overextended well
we've done that yeah well we've done
that the hospitals are fine we have beds
everyone's fine so now what is it yeah
cuz you told us to shut down to level
the curtain i hospital well we de now
we're good Sweden had no shutdown
well they different mentality yes it's a
different society more orderly the
follow rules they have about eight
million people I think with a million
immigrants yep it's a different
demographics to have to be careful but
they never shut down there was just very
smart about it apparently and there's
some controversy there
premier said by May they're gonna have a
herd immunity I think that we are going
to look back I've said this a bunch
times I I feel we're gonna look back and
say again there was a smarter way to do
this in a laughing we're gonna happen
and I'm I guess I'm just super worried
about I find myself more and more
worried about the long-term
ramifications of this
I was it worth it no we need what we
need we need Texas Atlanta Ohio and
Florida to be okay yes and then it's
gonna put pressure on California's we're
gonna be the last ones to open up fully
because San Francisco they extend all
the way to June but I you know and I see
here's the thing like I go back and
forth I go back and forth for a couple
of reasons one I'm sure a lot of us do
yeah I'm not a doctor right so I can
only I don't know sorry though right
right look at the stats dude but but
here's the thing depending on what this
is the this is what I think the problem
was see with this internet basically you
want facts you can find facts that back
up whatever you want them that's why we
need our leaders to be viewed earlier I
don't have to preserve a unified what's
it I don't know I want my leaders like
you hide it anywhere yeah like I posted
this article I sent you yeah Travis I
free his name
oh no the Stanford no no no no the NBA
yeah I'm free is named Travis something
but he's in B again but he listed out
all the stuff right and it's like ice
blast out when people are send me stuff
well no no that this this and I'm like
dude you're gonna find whatever you want
sperm you're gonna find you do you know
what this time we do know stat yeah and
you can you can go from what you want
off that you know
yeah well that's for sure uh a hundred
percent I think for me like now that you
we've seen what it did and does and we
know stats I was not mad and am not mad
that these extreme measures were taken
because we were dealing with something
that was unknown jong-kook about h1n1 if
h1 I want to hit today right with
Internet with the internet but that's
it's going on yeah I think what would
have happened because it was kids doctor
was here he said it was routinely
killing people in their forties fifties
30s I believe that back then with this
mentality today we would shut down with
the same vibrate here's what it would
have been unnecessary I got it Josh I'm
always I'll suck yeah but I'm not
opposed with the quarantine and lock him
down alright we did we've done it for
about forty five days now we we've
leveled the curve hardly wait morning
we've dominates totally ready we've
lovely curve we did it the house was on
overwhelm open up dude yep tell me what
it well but now we got to make sure it
is there could be a rise but you don't
know that yeah let's find out totally
with
and I feel all the businesses are
getting shut down places like comedy
clubs should open but instead of 500
people packed in there let's see what if
you get 200 200 you know what I mean let
them wear masks yeah a hundred percent
bin that that's that's phase two
according to right plan
I'm face now it's no eye space for Bubba
I think it's fair I think face phase two
is reopening retail retail in and yeah
sure I don't think it's entertainment I
think it is bars theaters movie theaters
his face too but but I heard that but
the bidding wars like arenas theaters I
think Marvel pushed their Black Widow
released so 2021 yes that's right
isn't it right summer they want summer
releases that's when you make all your
money back and so they were on stage too
did you see this those include
workplaces like factories not good but
curbside pickup retail store schools and
childcare facilities as well to reopen
yeah so stage three will be high risk
business did you today Bradley's what
we're talking about dates for Peter so
we got stage three that's did you some
ways for that's months away did you see
that AMC today cinema AMC said today
they're never gonna carry another
Universal yeah movie why was huge
because Universal controls came out and
made a million 100 million dollars in
the first three days a lot it seven
times
okay five hundred million dollars all
three days so they said this is going to
change how we do it as you make more
money when you scream this is how that
we're gonna change id's
well but I think you may I think it cost
you less because you lot of some done
yeah but 7 times about you cut you more
but that one trip to the theater costs
you how much three tickets are seeing
fools and twenty dollars is a deal for
you how [ __ ] yeah actually you're right
yeah right 500 $140 though you know yeah
but yeah but you were the dumb one who
bought its kid oh wait dinner with
dinner with snacks with parking decide
if well if I went to movie theaters
seven times that how much money the
thousand dollars yeah it's a lot of
[ __ ] money
this is gonna change how people release
your
this is how gonna change how they
release their movies so Universal is mad
at Universal because you MC said yeah
Universal said we're gonna release it in
theaters and at home you have to help
people and kids you [ __ ] it and the an
a.m. seems like your that's too big of a
radical change for us because it'll [ __ ]
their business I'll [ __ ] their business
dude everybody's going Direct TV
everyone's going to Rack pretty silly me
but there's some movie like you want to
see in the theater correct kids movies
but but if you're but if you're AMC why
are you mad dude trolls getting released
gave those kids and parents a short
amount of time to be happy for once but
you're mad because when you come out of
this and everybody releases at home man
instead of [ __ ] taking some for small
kids to a movie theater and getting
another car I'm gonna do it at my
[ __ ] house are you kidding I made it
was so crumb you're welcome more papa
trolls today [ __ ] yeah yeah that trolls
today man and the pajamas so wearing
your pajamas you can sleep on your couch
while he's watching the I used it he'll
see when I'm being bad I used to have to
I used to take when I was single I used
to take the kids to movie theaters for
naps but and I would fall asleep because
the only time but I would make sure I
was touching all three of them so thanks
to oh dude right that I would know they
move there's one time we went and saw
this a long time ago what was that Adam
stay on their movie switch snitch with
their remote control switch oh my god no
switch right with the remote control
switch I was sorry
great movie sad movie that's the thing I
was in they're super so there was a
father-son scene and I started to tear
up a little bit supers and my son leans
over to me and he goes hey oh yeah and
he goes yeah man but dad like have you
seen on word while your kids aren't on
word is uh it's a new Disney movie it's
so goddamn good it's about two brothers
one older brother one younger just like
my kids one older one younger and their
dad passed away and they have magic to
bring him back
oh his feet his body cuz but yeah they
try the magic in justice we come back so
they're searching to find the rest like
this magic formula to bring the whole
dad back and then that spoiler alert in
three
- one so the the kids go through this
whole journey and at the end the younger
brother realizes that his older brother
was showing him and like he was the
father figure
dude did you cry wow I teared up a
little yeah I teared up my second idea
I'm not sure if you ever saw that movie
up oh yeah first five minutes I'm crying
I'm like am i [ __ ] crying in the five
minutes and quince is so good oh my god
this you've never seen this right I've
never seen any of those movies but I
hear there are some minions or
Despicable Me yes Milana Coco that's
cause my kids oh yeah hope goes findt
which is the one for me with my kids
Lion King I probably saw I do man I get
four grand Getti dude that's right so
dude you have four grandkids I can't
believe you were a single dad dude four
grandkids yeah
do you touched you are you in touch with
mom uh
with my ex yeah no she's remarried and
lives in Seattle the kids um you know I
don't even it's not my business they're
all grown ups you know so they can hold
it
[ __ ] man you know my oldest son is 27
and then my daughter is 25 and then
Jacob just turned 23 oh and I would see
Jacob at space actual speech oh yeah
daddy got canceled yeah dude he's living
at my house yeah yeah it's a great show
great CEO said it best comedy central
could find a gold brick and they'd paint
it brown they it was the first time
anybody has been talking about Comedy
Central in I don't know her son they're
irrelevant yeah yeah I don't have toss
point of South Park but it's like you're
not gonna go for anything new Spade show
was [ __ ] great great and middle
country I'm great for color yeah people
just didn't pick it up I bet another
network picks it up I think so I bet you
man I bet you it was budgetary I think
Viacom is hemorrhaging cash in the last
month or so you know Adam Bay from the
comic store was the ghetto runner hmm
well the talent Booker terribly talent
Parker teller Tom a Brad the guys who
ran Chelsea were the
if started that you know Tom McGrath yep
that yeah they started that show but but
but I think it'll end up somewhere else
man it was so good he got the best
[ __ ] he crushed it dude a Jim Carrey
huh his interviews with Sandler are to
me man Sandler's my oh yeah for me my
hair out of North Star
I'll tell you what his spirit award
speech told me everything you needed to
know about that dude he knew he wasn't
gonna win an Oscar he bashed the Oscars
and those fancy fox- won it he made sure
he thanked all of the people behind the
scenes from his comedy movies for the
last 20 years you know of the people
because he was he was like I can never
get any I haven't ever had a chance to
publicly thank these people because I
he's 90 years that's a [ __ ] how much
money that dudes made though come on
know what you're [ __ ] you know there's
blockbusters you're talking Big Daddy
anger-management [ __ ] you've waterboy
still doing happy gilmore Billy Madison
right let me ask you straight dude if
you went best if some is if you took a
comics or that there is the best three
or best three comedy movies right I
don't know if you find anybody that
beats of Beverly Hills Cop Trading
Places and 48 hours I disagree happy
gilmore Billy Madison those beat Eddie
Murphy's to me I'm younger right what
about Will Ferrell we I don't know how
dude happy gilmore Madison Talladega
Nights stepbrothers waterboy mater water
boys boy I've never seen cool I've never
seen an atom Sam
what guys I stopped out of here dude
chuckles Larry let me back in the group
never watch one got one have you not
watched his latest comedy special oh it
was great [ __ ] kids oh you would love
his music guitar very similar to well
yeah man I like Longest Yard come on
dude you never seen the longest Chardon
with football you never see Joe Diaz
oh joy Diaz is so thick and them how big
is he enough [ __ ] so big they were
worried about
you know what a my favorite okay when
I'll do the wedding senior dude oh the
very first time okay man look at this
look at that right there look at that
dude
you caught me now
with that picture in mind the very first
time he tried ecstasy I had given it to
him right and he went over to this
woman's house who he was dating at the
time dating is wrong word she had a
restraining order against me right and
he go he was like give me one of those
ecstasy pills I'm going over see and I'm
not gonna say her name and so you went
over right now they had a weird
relationship and so they went in and
they were gonna mess around but she had
told her neighbor you see this dude
call the cops oh so they're about to get
into it and Joey just taking his ecstasy
and there's a knock on the door police
so she goes and opens the door and she's
like he's like the cops like we're here
this guy's in here and she's like no
he's like well we got to come in and
take a look and she told me I said so
did they find him and she said the
police officer said ma'am why is your
mattress breathing cuz he was under the
bed and he the first time he took
ecstasy
he said it started to hit him in the
back seat of a cop car cuffed and he
started to just roll his brains oh yeah
man it's fantastic you know he's in The
Sopranos movie yes and you know what's
interesting I think he says you start
off there's a little roll yeah he
[ __ ] nailed it so they keep them do
more more and more is that movie coming
out I think it's got postponed right
right right it's good and I cuz I think
David Kelley's a little old or too I'm
not sure he wants to but also with Joey
Diaz it's like dude of course he's in
Sopranos of course you put him in
surprise yeah he listen guys I mean I
could write a Joey Diaz story plan Oh
Tom Berenger the he okay my the first
time I realized that this dude is just a
giant teddy bear I used to run this
place in Pioneer Square
in Seattle and when he first came to
Seattle I hired him to work the door
and on Tuesday nights I had a night
there a fetish night because I like
weird [ __ ] and I like to watch people do
weird [ __ ] and you know what's the first
time I'd ever seen some a dude lay under
a glass table and pay a hundred dollars
to watch a girl [ __ ] on the table I
don't like that no I don't like that
either but I had to see it once just to
see what was going on you know what I
mean it's like no Carter yeah think
about the girl - is willing to do that
this dude literally dick out jack now
yeah the whole time Wow
yeah I don't know how you find out
that's your thing but how many things do
you go through that's the one got that
great bit about that or he goes before
the Internet like how would you find out
somebody's in the same fetish you're
yeah I'm gonna go pee let's run your
face [ __ ] mixer you know it's funny I
bet you'd nurse warts and said that out
loud before but so we there was one
there was one night the first night he
worked there well there were these two
old queens dressed like basically two
women from gone with the wind and they
had parasols and they were talking to
each other and it was hilarious and was
super fun but they just started to yell
at each other real loud guy Joey I know
come on I know you got to get these guys
out of here and he was well they looked
like they had a good time I'm like no
man you gotta they're screaming at each
other it's it's you gotta get him out
here and he goes okay and he goes hey
and you know he's straight like his
vernacular he when he doesn't think he's
being offensive it's just the way he
talks
yeah hey hey come on you two queens you
gotta go in there like why they just
want you out of here yeah I think you're
dressed nice but you gotta go and so he
grabs them by one elbow it's just to
walk him out well they have their
parasols and they're they're just back
and he's walking out getting hit he
called him umbrella stop hitting me with
your umbrellas but he's laughing the
whole way out
he came back inside I go you didn't get
mad he goes that was the funniest
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's ever happened to me
yeah he goes they just beat me up with
her
there's no they kidnapped a guy and I
was like laughing yeah so goes hey he's
not joking no he's not yeah yeah he had
that guy on his podcast yeah he brought
him back right he kidnap he kid down his
back over you know what yeah and he told
me he was I go you kidnapped a guy he
was yeah but he was a drug dealer I'm
like that's okay yeah it's still kidnap
he was it yeah but it's okay my um I
still probably know why he went to jail
right I believe so yeah yeah yeah well
in the in Seattle he went to jail for a
there he is um for something completely
different he still can't go to Seattle
cuz I think he's got a warrant out there
you can't go to see Ellen one other
place to anywhere outside of the United
States that's the one yeah I would I
still say if you tell me Joey Diaz calls
on the ball today
did ya there's nobody else in the world
who has that headline on top of high
school I have his first headshot on here
somewhere but you know you know he
obviously he used to babysit my kids and
I found one of his a little beautiful
heiress dude come on man he looks like
you sell Welcome Back Kotter he looks
like Juan Epstein right [ __ ] there um
wait a second where where is Joey's the
best cuz we have the same eight we all
have the same agent Justin and just ago
Hotel Justin goes we sent him Brennan
job and then Justin tell him and then
Joey called me go you're not [ __ ]
going there you need help tell me what
to do and I called Justin like hey man
so I'm not I'm not going to New Jersey
I'm not playing that place and I'm not
flying there you think we just talked to
Joey I'm like yeah man he but dude so we
stole the safe once I think I've told
you this story before but we stole a
safe once and this epitomizes him for me
also after I was like hey man so he's
like me right now I said he
it's gonna he can't look like a young
Andre the Giant in that picture yeah but
I said hey man here's the deal I said if
we get caught he goes man if we get
caught don't worry about it I said
what'd he mean he goes well I'm just
gonna say I took the safe
I said why this is what's his mentality
you know he didn't think he was gonna
live to 50 you know his daughter saved
his life yeah but he said to me he was
Yemen but if if we get caught I'll go to
jail he said you got a family who you
have people in this world who love you I
don't have anybody's mom does yeah all
of them right he was like I who cares if
I go to jail and that was his mentality
yeah he was like who cares if I go to
the most loving guy yeah the best yeah
he is he's also man one of the few dudes
who I'll pick up the phone for I'm like
mostly what you're calling I'm like I
know why is this dude attack sorry I'll
go in studio text me he calls me ya know
he's not gonna text you he's just not
kind of thing he'll text me gross
pictures and weird videos post pictures
or his pictures he sent me yeah
but told me the other day worried about
corona and not being on the tour I'm
like Joey I'm good man yeah he's like
you [ __ ] focus on the podcast this
listen man he's like everybody's big
brother I know when do you think we're
gonna be back to touring end of June
because I was shown spoken that's sold
out almost I would say July I would say
July again Josh I just told you I'm
sorry besides for Brendan to pay
attention yeah yeah hey clean I I think
it's that's the plant-based diet that's
wrong in my brain now now what do you
have for lunch after your your
plant-based [ __ ] annoying protein
shake
well I'll usually have some sort of bowl
of greens with some sort of fish on top
of it like a tuna uh tuna wrap every
registration every day I fish three
times a week and then what about din din
din din and then it's always tricky
little tricky right yeah din dins a
little tricky but I will tell you man
I am I bet you I'm 85% plant-based not
because I think it's better like if I'm
not anti me it makes me feel better yeah
that's the only reason I don't
anyone who's ever gotten plant-based
where they didn't feel better yeah it's
just so hard to do it last night I did
it yeah I was like would you do
I had a cauliflower and chicken for
lunch
yeah plant-based but mainly called clam
face chicken and that and I had a shake
at a mainly green shake and for dinner I
had lettuce wraps that have sprouts
spinach and the healthiest [ __ ] let me
tell you some Brian the best I've ever
done in my life [ __ ] right now
Jesus best I've ever have felt in my
life although it was impossible to keep
up I did I read a book called beans
greens nuts and seeds
yeah and I got awful it was [ __ ]
terrible sand I tried it for three
months
you're the positives your poop comes out
of you like it's on a waterslide no you
had a problem it goes woo it shoots out
you barely need toilet paper yeah it's
like clean the way it's supposed to
happen
great your Energy's great you feel good
shredded however you're hungry all the
time every minute of the [ __ ] boy
that is a shake today all you can think
about is what you're eating next yeah
that's a problem it's really it ruins my
life yeah right now it's just a box
can't wait to get done with this and
then go to chop I have a lettuce wrap I
kidding I had elk sausage and four
different kinds of cheese with fig jam
yesterday on sourdough pople that might
explain your belly though that's why my
belly oh hey stop there hey friend I had
Frank point is really just engine I know
he did it again last night
we walk around the Jimmy goes junk in
the belly huh you don't tell him you
said that me yesterday yeah he goes leak
his belly a little bit dude no it's a
problem and then check this out and then
I had to march into rice I had drunken
noodles with [ __ ] chicks fried
chicken I mean I went booty giving all
this [ __ ] place called Wallflower
it's best best [ __ ] some of the best
food inventor quit eating all that and I
just stopped yeah it's a little bit I
might have a little problem I I do think
it's funny that you were like I don't
know I'm didn't wait I mean fried
chicken and milk but then he blamed it
on the milk yeah yeah
they just listed off a shitload of stuff
you just mentioned fried chicken noodles
with fried chicken sorry hey you know
what Brian it's worth it dude you look
fine
you do I don't think that right a little
bit of tummy you look like yellow
bastard from Sin City not a big deal
bring him up Jen not identical you
shaved your head
let me see by the way I'm so glad your
hair grew out a little bit when it was
that okay okay oh you look identical to
him that's a great face that's not bad
dude yeah no that's not don't make me
get Josh oiled up that dude that is not
a handle mastered no man he's a
pedophile - I gotta pee dude we're gonna
take a break
come on young da Marrero was he doing
the same style jokes very young Arsenio
Hall I'm sorry it was Dom's telling the
same style was he the same style our era
was a killer he stood back yes I'll
still yeah oh yeah about the laugh I got
when I was just starting us up and they
wanted Dom to go before me cuz do
something I was like [ __ ] dude and Dom
comes back he owes I'm not gonna marry
you
I want you to do well I'm not gonna bury
him he's at least and he literally did
like his see material yeah it was the
snake that's when I do yeah that's when
I was seeing him and he's one of the
best people on the [ __ ] earth Oh his
timing is ridiculous his and such man
great guy yeah such as groundwork
[ __ ] guy aq student at the Laugh
Factory the last time I was there
he's doing crowd work you know how long
you been dating just lighting people up
are you how much material you think he's
gone for real he's got you know I would
say he's got an hour yeah I mean
probably Dom is both funny and great tom
has been funny and Dom said at Dom has
been making his living a very very good
living since 1987 you know he really
hasn't had to look at a price tag since
thank you
seven that's Kyle because I feel very
lucky me Dom DOM is crushed Dom he's
such a nice yeah he's one of the greats
he's one he's actually one of the greats
all for sure and and recognizes so among
yeah I would tell you they're like
referring I've been at the store now for
a bunch of years for me if you're if
you're saying who's 15 minutes in the in
the Oh are not necessarily the main room
with 15 minutes in the oh are at their
peak who wrecks that room the most and I
would tell you for me not for me is Joey
like Joey at 15 minutes at full speed is
a [ __ ] Bobby Lee's pretty good yeah
but there's some nice you go down there
you look at that line up and you're like
well who's following that oh well who's
for oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah daliyah to Halil without it out
right that room with how did dad Brogan
back in the day he wrote you brokenness
that when he used to close with that one
where I was on the stool
yeah the Tiger Tiger fight that tiger
you know the heart and I've seen Joey
that was 21 years ago
that's how long he's been crushed
obviously Joey kills in the mate I've
seen Joey crush in the main room you
know who I absolutely see destroy the
main room where I was like holy [ __ ] the
rooms [ __ ] vibrating was Chris Rock's
brother Tony Tony Tony scary cool
Tony's great at to be keen on he's but
Donnell to man Don oh yeah you know by
the way and if you would find the people
who they either bomb or crush like to me
nobody bombed or crushed the leg Brody
Brody could destroy the room it's a
style where people were either but it
wasn't a big writer of not at all Brody
Brody was always a very sort of I get
sad when I see his face but but you know
I said Joey and to watch the two of them
to watch Brody Brody brought a homeless
clown onstage one night who's threatened
to kill everybody in the room because
Brody touched him he goes you touch my
[ __ ] shoulder one more time I'll
murder everybody in that's right
that it's such a shame yeah yeah man
that was it I never knew I didn't know
Brody I mean I saw more yeah I never
knew I didn't know him well enough to
know he was going through what he was
going through I didn't know yeah you
know I don't think change switch
medications right yeah I don't think
anybody at the time knew really it
didn't help two days before he was
talking to me about touring and what he
should so I was like it's such a [ __ ]
yeah man it was absolutely brutal my
favorite Brody story that I was there
the night he changed I've always called
him Steve because I was introduced to
him as Steve Brody and so one night he
got off stage in Seattle and he bombed
the way only he can [ __ ] bomb where
he was talking about if he's like I
think he closed with because he was mad
because they weren't laughing he goes I
don't think you guys understand you know
do you know how hard it is for a single
man with a hairy back to shave his own
back and then he lifted up his shirt he
goes like a problem areas and there were
just like two patches and he clearly
couldn't reach with his hand I was glad
feeling it no he's the comic was
laughing right but he walks off stage
and he goes Steve Brody isn't funny and
I go what do you mean he I go that was
really funny he's not he goes you know
who's funny I go who he goes Brody
Stevens I said who's that he said you'll
see you tomorrow and he came back as the
guy you know yeah a completely different
one I tell until I die
but weird to change your name and just
the next day he was a different guy
different cadence differently every
[ __ ] thing but nobody bombed the way
he or Joe Diaz to man Joey used to wear
a three-piece suit on stage and pace
like Chris Rock there are a lot of big
names what's that one say who I've seen
who people all like revered I seen it
day yeah hard yeah all that but anybody
can he did no I mean are you saying the
contentiously date there were guys who
didn't get funny until later on there
yeah yeah absolutely but you know what
though though I to me those people
generally are funnier because when you
learn to eat [ __ ]
repeatedly you
a skin that you also just get better and
you're you know those guys we're usually
working they were trying to be authentic
and working and before you figure your
voice out and how to string that
together it can be clumsy and sometimes
you're working off anger only and then
you start to realize this more the lot
of things that go on with you what do I
text you every time after I see you on
stage do you know every time I see him
because it blows me away and this isn't
me second a dick but your your level of
commitment to your bids and the and how
ridiculous like some people for the
first time watching you like my wife she
was like I thought he was telling a real
story I'm like no no he doesn't ride a
horse I'm like I don't think so but like
but that you learn that over the years
that's what I'm gonna do I love acting
you know
yeah dude like that crazy if you don't
think those shoes like building those by
the way those shoes really pretty strong
women in my age but sounds are they no.9
oh they're not man's shoes right 9 those
are 10 mm okay oh yeah yeah I'm nine I
didn't know I wasn't trying to be funny
what do you wear Josh 10 half yeah those
would fit Josh these this is a puma guy
though I am a bit outward some Pumas I
like Puma D Andres guys bring up the G
Andres for me and and with the Public
Enemies those are my have you seen the
Public Enemy show you could do those
Pumas you gave me those MCM ones I
didn't realize how I don't really I
didn't realize dude I told you when I
gave them to you I don't know what would
you what those are oh my god those are
oh those are at the dacha yeah up top
left the top left you didn't realize why
those are so [ __ ] look pull up the
Public Enemies MCM said he sent me I was
like oh these are dope I know then see
him the brand me they're like you'd like
resale like eight nine dollars I see
them J sent them for you yeah I was like
hey these are supposed to a show I
couldn't make this one use out shoot and
look at the that one and in the high
tops I like the public am Puma dude I'm
telling you pull my New Balance
their [ __ ] cry
yes ooh yeah yeah Puma did a collab - I
forget who they did CLAB with how they
did one with Alexandra Queen Queens I
hope boom is an awesome they're awesome
their days they haven't always been
awesome I haven't been cool they've been
cool with like older people and like you
know tennis whatever but they recently
got hip yes the New Balance - they're
doing these collabs you know Pumas a
cool easy name to work off of it's just
a cool logo it's a cool name Puma my
simple mo I'd say how did you learn
involved with pool you know what
management you think you just push
Poulos did a long time ago but they're
really man here's the deal
I like I like people who aren't [ __ ]
and I like and so everybody I've met at
that brand has been super cool they are
they you know that thing that I do with
those teenage kids every year yes
microscope
you always help yet and so there's a
there's groups of teenage kids who don't
have families that we donate to every
year right and Puma every year around
Christmas sends me hundred pairs of
shoes for these kids hundred pairs and
so I've a ton more stuff by the way for
those kids and then and throughout the
year I'll say hey I'm gonna like I work
with Steve Simone I'm like hey this home
needs and they gonna have will send you
over 50 pairs of shoes and so and
they're sending shoes for that and
they're just good people man so I like
to push out if they're gonna see that
they've gotten kind of hip yeah you know
like you see it in the in the streets
yeah their MA and mouthsize MLS the
workout shoes are I like that you keep
saying yeah because I need to play a
hundred percent I want to I don't like
these uh-huh they're they might be the
most impossible shoes you for that let's
get the [ __ ] out of there of those I'm a
hundred percent but don't I don't want
to crazy no just Brian in the classic
pool looks like a black suede or come on
you go and you could go in talk to them
and pick out what you want really
absolutely I screw up like that they're
the classic Pumas the Clyde the white
and blues there and do you like the
Suede's at all or not only those suede
to be done in the black number room yeah
yeah yeah they've green the the the the
Pumas are though I like things on some
big athletes too much they have Kylie
and they just signed some basketball
players but they'll each other
they had like a deal with her for a hot
minute right yeah I thought like a lot
of these yeah man we'll definitely set
that up for you all right yeah and
they're really solid and last time Josh
Thole on an ox of 50 shoes right yeah
but those an cm's dude those that's what
you need those MCM sr6 are those
deandra's I got I can't I like those
though classic see yeah man I'm gonna
start wearing those and then I'm cool
yeah I think you could even do something
like this man no I think so those are
cool you don't think find those I think
you could do this not for Brian
I like cuz it gives you some little
splash man you'll spot a little splash
splash you're not too crazy especially
high thoughts but I suffer Brian no no I
think the Suede's dude he'll Ross wait
wait I need some Suede's
well we're all set in current events I
mean just I jump over come on let's go
see the maroon the black on our pump now
Paul you don't leave us I like that I
happened where those shoes and where
those yep but set it up and and
comfortable too man oh they comfy as
[ __ ] yeah the pink one
they sign big deals to what those are
called they say some big deals too with
basketball players they just did I think
jay-z's on board I think so too
yeah jay-z yeah he's like the head of
towners jay-z I think all the ball kids
just sandwiches I would wear those I'm
States all the time like I would does
beauty you don't hear what's crazy that
Dad you know with levar ball yeah it was
give him [ __ ] has to be doing something
right his son mellow right was number
two I think one of the one of them was
number two for the Lakers the other one
he's coming out this year's me the
number one pick they think that and by
the way third one bought a basketball
team they bought a basketball team in
Australia third one who's in Australia
yeah it's gonna come over here they
think he's gonna be a lottery pick to
[ __ ] all three his dad knows how to turn
right you know what his dad pipe down
you don't see him anymore do you Mario
cuz he was the problem you know the
Lakers banned them from being on the
court cuz you do interviews afterwards
like did your distraction can have and
he was a so Magic Johnson his son went
to New Orleans on the pelicans but he's
a ball he's a good player
solid player imagine having three kids
and they all play professionals in the
chances of that on the NBA do you know
we did a i-i-i-i a long time ago sold
the script to sandler with a guy named
Jonathan check real story about a
baseball team
Canoga in Canoga Park in the early 60s
it was a traveling all-star team and
seven kids off of that traveling
all-star team played major league
baseball seven out of the 12 kids that's
all nothing crazy is that a crazy
numbers crazy there's a place a crazy
junior mother
unbeliev ember that read I did for a
Showtime there's this documentary coming
out it's somewhere and I think Marilyn
or Baltimore it has something like ten
people out in the past six or seven
years ten they're from the same it's
like a mile radius all first-round draft
picks in the NBA I get ten miles mile
radius
I didn't whether you Pennsylvania that
way for a while with football no spread
out with quarterbacks but their gears
huh it's it's if there's a place in
Florida where like Antonio yeah all
those monsters they come from the same
place but I didn't play with one
professional athlete I didn't in my high
school like if there was a guy that was
over 250 we were like this don't touch
that guy like we didn't play I mean I
tried to hit a ball against a kid who
was a pitcher and known and oh here dude
here it is so check this out
how many players from in high school
were draft in the NBA the answer is none
you're in the overwhelming majority has
only three out of 10,000 kids go on to
make the league well for the NBA guard
Quinn cook five of his high school
teammates made it this story is not
uncommon in his hometown of Prince
George's County Maryland where 35
players since 2035 she since 2000 made
the NBA and WNBA including Kevin Durant
Victor Oladipo Steve Francis marquel
faults which was a bust and I'm gonna
pick from Washington
Michael Beasley baller wmba pick Marissa
Coleman that is 13 and Isis do you know
nuts that is crazy but but those are
legit and by the way well the top three
are legit
it's easily and [ __ ] victor's I'm
super baller yeah man that's in that
crazy look why are my I think my high
school basketball team consisted of ten
white dudes yeah
ten ten might turn into would use guys
who go pro it I mean it's there I mean
you know they're just it's just that's
why you know what I used to coach my
son's baseball team and they were
fathers would come up to me be like what
do you think about what do we need to do
to get him ready you know if he wants to
make the pros I'm like oh he he's not
making did you see his son it felt for
years old yes son clearly has those
genes because the kid is so fast
does he have fast but he's also thick as
[ __ ] he's so thick and strong he's got a
really thick neck with traps he's four
years old raps ism dude and he run that
so fast he's like you can see it you're
like this kid has crazy speed how old is
he gonna be when he's bigger than me how
do you think what his hands are seven
[Applause]
speed he's real fast that's what I mean
it's not that he's giant he's not like
he's 86% I talked to his mom yeah it's
not that it's his it's his muscularity
already you can see his muscles in his
coordination and his funny touch
footballs mom mom Subaru yes but his
speed froze he's got calves that are
defined yeah he's got these perfect
little calves and a but you're like take
it easy he's never done this
he was Papa used to boom boom pow for
money I go yeah I used to fight for
money papa
and he goes oh I want to see I'm like I
didn't know where to start so I just I
start with a fight you want yeah yeah so
I just typed in I type in my name and
they had the Ultimate Fighter is like
clips from Britain shot from Walter and
fighter
so I showed him all the Ultimate Fighter
stuff he was obsessed with it you must
have loved it
he's a natural easy he loves contact
combat he's taking the ball dodge ball
he gets he gets mad he stamped his foot
in center crying he went like this way
stand his foot and then threw it back I
and he likes to charge you full speed
and hit you here's what here's what's
crazy though though my fault the five
month old compared to when Tiger was
five month old
I mean his feet are damn minute twice as
big his hands are twice as big he's
gonna be a little boys gonna be the calm
offensive tackle are you bigger than
your brother yes but my brother's
thicker his brother's easy 235 but lean
strongest funny and he's leaner than me
who was when in fights growing up oh
it's my brother my records one in 10,000
yeah boy do you remember the one bread
alone II did the [ __ ] I did is he gonna
beat you up like all the fights I'm like
what did you guys stop fighting
physically cuz you guys have had some
they've had some personal arguments
around med school but his brother
brother if you get a wrong move his
brother would say you better know your
[ __ ] because that dude has fought it all
should have been a lawyers thought it
all through
he's got how old were you when you beat
him in the fight I was like seven but it
was a fluke I like caught him off guard
I'd like real anger issues yeah he had
to go to anger management used to really
beat me I love when did you guys stop
beating the [ __ ] out of each other what
a cool way did you punch each other in
the face yes he put he beat me up in
high school cuz he had this black
girlfriend she were a lot of lip gloss I
hated her Candice so I emptied out her
lip gloss pissed in it and then put it
back and then I then I hear her like
what the [ __ ] and I know how's that PEP
taste and he beat the [ __ ] up yeah man
does the last time yeah yeah yeah yeah
what way by Little Britain
how old were you I was a freshman I see
five I gotta tell you part of me
completely respects that move bro is oh
yeah he's so strong he's all tears I
think he benches bother me yeah he said
to me he goes what somebody's talking
about deadlifting in you guys and he he
goes he was we were eating and he's not
like this he just said it really matter
of factly because he was talking about
Brendan bends the bar when he deadlifts
like crazy
oh wait and then he goes he goes because
if you put five hundred
sound right now I'll lift it right now
like like like he's stupid sure he's
stupid strong like that's not 500 pounds
if you put 500 pounds down right now I
get up and lift it right now without how
old is he he's 2 years old me so he's 39
yeah the thing about Jay those his IQs
through the roof he was a computer
programmer my Samarra [ __ ] he's also my
tour manager so he goes every city with
me talk to him about whatever were your
brother man that is so fun books all the
hotel travel and you go brothers
brothers I'm gonna start fighting I try
to get you know we're brothers so yeah
that's a great picture of us that's at
the White House dude that's friend Jason
Juden everybody buddy's looking super
thick oh my god even you look thick
you're not bad I look a little thick
yeah everybody's looking not really made
a shirt they made us wear suits but we
did a tour of the White House yeah
that's that guy our boy took us on a
tour like a like behind-the-scenes tour
and he goes you wouldn't believe how
Trump eats dude here's when Obama's here
is clean food egos Trump hotdogs
cheeseburgers all the time what a great
picture tater tots you know what I do
love a Tater Tot man I'd be to be that
guy on the end yeah he he's head and we
go Jason's head sweats all day long I'm
called big sweat Jason here's the other
thing about Jason like a serious O'Neal
yes but it has a serious girlfriend now
you won't talk about fashion all the
fashion stuff I get it goes from Jason -
j2me
he's in New York his serious girlfriend
but Jason as far as fashion no one knows
fashion better he goes Japan gets the
denim everything but also we go to New
York he goes what kind of food you like
Brendan I go I like this everybody knows
him he takes us these hole-in-the-wall
burger place pizza place he's on that
you start me at Prince Pizza I'm hitting
mitts reigns in Thailand I wouldn't want
to [ __ ] with him
that guy's giant watch that guarantees
[ __ ] left
meet the [ __ ] she's like a mini mark
hunt look at him I would never want to
fight what kill me [ __ ] look at that
and he looks heavy and fat he's a
schematic let me tell you something some
model but he works with say well
somebody hizmet has judged him
incorrectly and taking a [ __ ] but he's
got a guy I would try to [ __ ] with him
yet old in half but also he works with
Jay so he's a computer programmer
so Tim Buster and Jay they're all
computer so they're all smart is [ __ ]
and they're all are all fashion yes that
would be like so let go Brendan you need
get on this right now
way before everybody else yes there's
nothing worse than a nerd who can be
especially let it all cost you hope that
you at least get that got shut up that's
at my special all of them came up for
the special insanity Chris Kattan there
which oh that's amazing that guy's 217
ERA Ned like eats like eats lives on
doughnuts and is could me Moishe I he
was number one number three dropping or
something in the NFL he's the first pick
in the second round for the st. Louis
Rams he's the biggest freak you've ever
met he makes Brendan look like like like
he's why I have a complex yeah I don't
never thought I was big because I use my
best friend he's so shredding Hey look
kind of like you ran this forty with his
shirt off it was all do you know it's
crazy is his arm is big it's a sure uh
supposed to live he spills a four or
five - oh my it was about a four four
he's built like a [ __ ] super oh they
did - 22 25 I think 32 times what I did
and I'll in the NFL Detroit Tigers right
runs a [ __ ] sale route catch the ball
see ya dude he's and then I remember I
remember we're playing in the Houston
ball game you're playing six six six six
to 60 around a four five forty we're
playing it in the Houston ball against
UTEP they throw him this like fade route
he catches it and they had a safety
garden um and the safety can't catch him
he runs like a 60-yard touchdown and our
head coach Gary Barnett goes he's going
the NFL like that and he was a junior
then and just like oh yeah he is yeah
they're almost like oh yeah it's crazy
yeah it's so weird how big and strong is
you
you know again you know transitioning he
went oh cool I'm into his buddy Austin
whose good friend of mine Austin goes
I'm in the flipping houses real estate
Joe goes on VES than that they start
this business they don't want the
biggest they invest in real estate and
flipping houses he's a millionaire from
that now I know what he does I go bring
a brand mop yeah bring that picture up
where they're at their beach he got cut
from the Buffalo Bills that's right
before fat Lavar Johnson in the pool the
day of the fight that's what he just
wanted the abs and stuff there's no fat
his legs are the stupidest things you
ever seen that be him just walking on
his haters do any smart way dude at the
very end is that Lister bowling for
right that's least er that's Cody and
Holly my show yeah all those guys those
guys are all that daddy fought my way
and we went to the beach well that's
that's all a disaster yeah actually the
toughest the least tough guy they're
fighting wise it might be Joe coffin
side like in terms of like if you had to
fight any of there's one of my main
trading partners though yeah send me a
big bomb Murray and a four five - four
five - that's so weird dude you know
what's funny to me is when like just
people were like yeah I think I could
run sub five there most people him in
the snow chance that's a terrible
picture of that card yes I'll see you
that would give us when he's in the suit
with the three guys on his business
sweats awesome he's with close friend of
mine and then that's the business
partner Joe belly oh he's a millionaire
from real estate now god bless man
that's so long Lord so awesome he's such
a good guy two kids just moved to
greenwood village good friends man yeah
man I miss those guys so he went to
every ex-girlfriend on the far left he
went yeah in the blonde he went to every
one of my fights he went to my family
special he's easy girl friend he was
gonna go to Europe when I was on tour in
Europe shows up Austin what is this
shaved head
well that's five years fighting dude I'm
about to shave my head again like barber
[ __ ] up my haircut shave and then my
son wants to shave his head I'm like
dude I'll do it with you I'm thinking of
my own hair a couple weeks ago
you got great hair at your age but yeah
thanks man it's a little [ __ ] up right
now but like cut away kitchen scissors
afterwards let's let me talk to Clarence
I'm clever I text him every week let me
talk to me I talk to me really every
week the greatest people his body hurts
my feelings a little bit I guess not
getting it out here soon guys you have
no idea I'd be on a straight [ __ ]
diet now and then he's eating [ __ ]
dessert every night oh my god if it
hurts my yeah oh how about when we get
ready for the NFL I'd go on I'd go on
seven mile jogs you would sit at home
you you know his you know his mommy no I
don't wanna energy maybe maybe you know
his mom and dad make me stay with me in
the summers when he's then I felt cuz I
would train my ass off yeah I would make
him train with me real did you guys
drink milk together you would drink milk
but he has different body Constitution I
met a training piece of [ __ ] yeah I'm a
little root digger that guy is a [ __ ]
Viking who eats who can live off a cow
yeah meat meat and cows last thing about
Japan I'm caught up kind of out route
against the Chicago Bears and trucked
Brian Urlacher hmm never heard of them
Hall of Famer yeah truck them dude
really
truck them yeah real estate
now he's milling and real estate I did I
did see him get up here I'll help you
out you was sparring a girl and got
wobbled on Jim big girl this big black
girl and clot was like I don't want to
do this he's like I need I need a male
and they're like you got to go with her
dude and she's like [ __ ] debts
there's been training for years so she
has decent technique and he's his hands
his hands were enough he's an NFL flames
and ran up and she [ __ ] she's oh I
stopped by the way last time I sparred
was in a sparring class and it was three
guys and three girls and the dude was
running I was like hey you're gonna spar
with Jarrod was a woman and I go um can
I start with guys he goes no you guys
Barbara Jarrod and I said to her hey I'm
not gonna hit you and she no she said to
me I know
now I thought she meant I I knew I was
gonna be polite oh wow
so I have never been
leg kicked before here dude she got me
twice there the second time hurts so
much
you drop a bit I draw no I dropped my
left arm when she lifted her leg up she
knocked my mouthpiece out of my mitt my
whole head just look across at bang bang
does it fakes then boom oh it was so
embarrassing that I just ran right at
her and I said to her I'm sorry
well he's impossible he was so happy so
so so she had just done you your Tom
technique and so he wrestled I think in
high school so he's just a monster oh my
god he's a nightmare
yet the hottest girl in the college ah
yeah we all live together man oh you're
the hottest girl of course so I guess
this is the end of the pilot then his
wife now is a [ __ ] scam
well well some you know I quit put this
[ __ ] back on see how it goes right now I
got enough Josh we love you man thanks
oh you're one of our favorites dude I
know it's gonna be easy when you're on
yeah it's always easy I appreciate you
guys good guy and you listen you're such
a good [ __ ] dude man no thanks I just
wanna say it out loud I mean I don't
mean that I mean that that's that's
important thing to be and to say you
make the world a better place
I'm just a [ __ ] special for free on
you you just say nice [ __ ] to me I don't
know may 7th a hilarity yeah yeah
well man I here's the thing I made him I
think it's important yeah I'll be there
oh you're not gonna be there not
scheduled dawg I would sock man I think
it's a great club though Brian I think
it's important and I do with Brenda too
man I think it's important when you're
friends with people and they do
something that you like or that you are
impressed with their I think it's
important to say it out loud to people
man it's never it's never always maybe
that you've always never lost a bet
you're great yeah it's important you for
25 years now I don't know how long I'm
gonna I know yeah when you have little
children yes yeah and you've always been
little oh my gosh you're sick um what
thanks guys I appreciate you guys having
me on man yo you're the best without a
name of the special is father of the
year go to my YouTube page and
I'm gonna get you on I do a show called
controlled chaos I'm Ryan on control
chaos man I'm not in sync but you don't
wanna you told me you didn't wanna zoom
well can't we keep em comin person is
but right now it's zoom because the
studio has an open but when the studio
is open again when I get open it is it
your studio now but they don't want to
have that many people it's three people
but but we're shirt is this cool it was
opening for me and dumping off any he
brought he would come out with a t-shirt
and he would go is this cool and I go
it's very gay yeah they go back I come
back and I go even Gary and sewed of
ghosts you have to stop doing that cuz
he's compulsive it said to me because
I'll kick a dead horse until it's yeah
yeah I made him change the shirt 15
times like he came out finally and he
had a tank that bomb where his hair was
coming out of his and I go perfect but
he's so angry he's just like in the face
chris is walking around his arms all
Langley I don't give a [ __ ] Chris said I
would never find a guy who you wouldn't
I use no cuz we met these guys and they
were Navy SEALs and Chris knew him from
high school and I go those guys are Navy
SEALs exist yeah I don't get whatever I
go how do you not care that's so cool
yeah okay and he's like I don't I do
they're cool whatever
I go you don't care about is how he goes
no I go what would it take to fight you
he goes I don't know maybe maybe if you
hit my mom I think my mom would never
fight here ya loose by the way special
most fourth the fourth most watched
thing in America on Netflix amazing hey
man you know he is a crazy combination
of fun
man oh boy but anyway man and and I'm
gonna add one more in there that you're
not gonna like but he has Danes charm
I would watch Dane at the Laugh Factory
even when I wasn't into his material and
I was like this is the most watchable
mother foster the most watchable do is
Chris right yeah man emotion watchable
bottom here's that it factor but he but
so he has that watch ability he but he's
become such a great writer like his
jokes are like legitimate like wealth
correct when I told him to now he has a
son right I think Cal helped a lot close
Calvin Chadwicks yeah yeah yeah I know
they were thinking Jack Calvin so now
the materials can get from the kids dude
wait I'm telling you man the kids if you
want if you will talk about them you
don't even have to give your opinions or
relate to it though every single you
know my that's father dear
this special father of the year is an
hour special and the whole premise is
every man gets to a point in their life
where they look at their dad and they
think I could beat the [ __ ] out of this
guy and this whole special is about my
son asking me to fight in the front yard
that's let's see in today's really fun
right yep it's it's a it's an hour
basically it's one basic long story I've
seen it and so it is it's look at that 9
million views 9 million like this
special has because it's relatable and
its story so it's like the best part
about having kids is that we can all
tell our individual stories nobody like
well so [ __ ] Brenda know the story
yeah it's your version or version of
your every Thai stick it will end on
this did you ever try sitting up your
dad yes
you know might my dad I was too afraid
my dad's a toughie
my name is so much bigger I'm certain my
to I'm terrified of my dad I was and I
remember all the kids were getting notes
from their parents to take their senior
to take it off the ditch and ask my
daddy is not happening yet to be in
school man I go yeah everybody's doing
it's not happening I go I [ __ ] I'll do
it myself and walked away and I've never
disrespect my dad
ever do I'm [ __ ] I figure out myself I
walk away and I see her through a
[ __ ] pen I go to turn o against holy
[ __ ] yeah yeah there's a you use me use
my my dad my dad hears it know your
dad's a very big guy a new Clinton stays
in shape
he's in better shape than my father was
just a giant Irish guy who I knew there
was a there was just a point where I was
gonna get my neck broken you got to be
careful I mean I'm not a big guy but
blouses see you as get recruited oh my
god but but you're you in brand here's
what you'll find out because your kids
are gonna be big right high school at
college high school here's what you find
out you find out real quick as a as a
father and this is my dad because when
Jacob challenged me to fight I called my
dad and I'm like what's the deal cuz I
remembered fighting we all I had three
older brothers we all took a turn of my
dad we remember vividly my oldest
brother getting us all pumped up I'm
gonna go [ __ ] dad we were all behind it
buddy let's go wait and he was like I'm
gonna make the rules in this house he
was like yeah you know we were all
behind them you know cuz he's the big
brother he's unbeatable and Jara yeah
and he walked out back and my dad was on
the porch smoking a cigar like what and
my brother comes out and goes hey we're
fine today old man and my dad goes okay
and he stands up and my brother goes and
let me tell you something and before he
could get another word out of his mouth
my dad just kicked him in the nuts
and he dropped to the ground and my dad
takes a puff had a cigar and he goes
don't talk when you want to fight son I
walked inside the house this dude's a
[ __ ] date he does anybody else dude
and you know why I knew he wasn't
worried he didn't ever took the cigar
out of his mouth he was if you don't
take a cigar out of your mouth going
into a fight you do my son you've even
my son at for a test me don't hit her
test so you don't think I'm strong on my
puppet you're never gonna be strong with
me again ya never gonna be yeah you mean
my album and I your system he might so
mad my what if the two of them gang up
on it's gonna be problem
my father my father because he's just
such a big guys yeah and was so big so
he's gonna be stronger bigger than you
he's six four that's huge
6250 your dad is six four that he's
gotta take size 14 shoes he in there too
wide
he has to get is he's got my guests do
you have brothers sisters no I have a
sister dead of the CIA [ __ ] hehe my dad
my dad's got he's probably a piece but
my dad um hi I'm Rob was Nestle yeah I
got I gotta be but by the way I just I'm
not gonna tell you who but I did hear
story someone haka who said I've seen
Bryan's [ __ ] in the bathroom at the
picture Jeff no I'm good I'm good you
know yeah would you say sure yeah yes
happy what it's just his flaccid old
[ __ ] just I do well it's like this dude
it's no it's good but he take me in it's
important because you talk about your
[ __ ] body in your plant-based shake
but I put my neck against my dad I was I
was doing I was wrestling and I was
doing neck all my next stuff I thought I
have a strong neck because yeah my
mother said your neck looks thick and I
was like a thick neck and I went I went
let's see whose neck is stronger and I
we were he was kidding ready and we were
in the garage and I put my head against
his to see who could move their head and
he went like this he just went and he
doesn't exercise anymore like that and I
when I went oh let me try again you know
when guys beat you in armors yeah let me
try again like that let me know grinning
cuz like that again I go he's so big how
are you doing that I don't know I have a
strong neck he doesn't have a neck he
has a head and he's got a head and
shoulders you know so it was so
interesting to me to get be it's like
when you are muscled dudes who have um
just big cop eyes yeah that you're not
beating that I just want to let you know
that I as a grown man I don't arm
wrestle no me neither it's too dangerous
yeah people ask me like you do it all
the time I saw Larry the Cable Guy snap
some dudes arms it's on now I will fall
snap some dudes arm in the skybox at the
Gotham hunters game Larry the kiddies
are huge arms dude he snapped
right here yeah and I hate be you did
peace watch this
Larry's the arms are huge dude strong
he's built just like my uncle Charlie
and I speak that here we go you ready
I'm Larry the cable car that boy Nelson
there we go oh look at this is a young
cat man it's a he's the biggest Huskers
fan you very much and that dude's not
small not big I'm not gonna watch that
though that snaps take a look it's like
a house or something got it that's up at
the Huskers that happen your honor just
watch you're crazy if you don't think I
do
[Applause]
the bones just [ __ ] devalue probably
have a weaker fracture
you heard it right did you hear it
following us
that's crazy now that's now sure Larry
the Cable guy's are arms so I can scared
Brennan
by the way this is left you see what's
left here I saw his arms but I left him
show when he's younger Larry the cables
arms he's younger because Brandon
Brennan I don't think people realize
later the Cable guy's sells out Statham
a nice I didn't realize it because he's
not exhausted I did I did
we sold fifty three thousand tickets I
opened for him he throw you here when
I'll say you open my oh I opened for him
for your friend with [ __ ] crushes on
he sold deep three thousand seats for a
show fifty three thousand he filled a
white common video
not just him it's just me I'm just
saying he got be got the way it wasn't
call the white comedy caller yeah the
White Collar Comedy Tour yeah yeah I
think you I don't think I don't think if
you learn technique guys who know
technique would be you but thing is high
technique it's crazy but I mean listen
tell me how many times you wash it over
the top yeah really
part of that also is part of what you
have is the leverage to that's huge have
you been beating my dudes oh yeah okay
clock can beat me we start wrestling
that dude's arm is a tree that it's a
nightmare
Oh claw that dude Klopfenstein coffin
sign did you spell that was he strong F
n st months restart KL o P Fe NS t ein
yeah Wow check out the beyblade s the P
hey he's this German as it gets that's
not Jewish yeah no they would it would
be like oh well you're gonna impregnate
everybody that's right well listen I'm
not gonna lie to you if there was gonna
be a dude who's gonna impregnate
everybody
yeah that's not a bad or you know that's
not a terrible choice you see his kids
is he smart yeah wicked yeah so he's
that bad you know he used to do he used
to in college I used to have he's really
good at math I saw him take my math
classes let me ask you question he got
me a see how much of that is is he is he
a gym rat or is he just naturally do
that he's a gym rat as in he likes a
lift but he like if you asked him like
run and he thought his frame he's that
that way anyway I mean that's just
totally he'll he'll eat McDonald's heats
Dunkin donut damn near every day now
[ __ ] he still shredded he's dunking down
every day
he can't stop being Dunkin Donuts and
he's shredded it's just so crying I'll
get you on my schedule my plant-based
schedule Hey look at that picture of him
look at this line there is my train back
go back that's a young picture of you
guys let me see that
get the [ __ ] out of here look at you
look the picture with him him with the
hat on there oh here yes that's a noise
are on the way to the fight yeah that's
not good that's in Brazil yeah doesn't
want to Brazil with me that's least her
bowling hits he was young he's my head
coach best coach I've ever had Keller
wrestler history I used to see him break
dudes he was like on defeat in high
school monster monster a good mother oh
my god that's his wife now on the right
look at you with your glass I know oh my
god fake glasses he's oh those are fake
that's good like you were wearing fake
glasses
yeah that's first time one of the first
times I met we hung out you had a great
jacket on a place you're in glasses and
I was like I said I was like that's a
great look on this dude your head style
I was like [ __ ] either the fake glasses
though he loved night as a movement yeah
love it a good time right yeah why
Joseph likes this necklace guys I got to
go get my son
now let's keep talking just a long
podcast it has it yeah better the best
we have you man thank you so free on
YouTube
yeah Gillian views yeah and check out
the controlled chaos which is
it's on dude yeah I told you man I
texted you and you said no a number
don't zoom yeah yeah yeah I'm in person
so we'll bring this yeah if I would
actually be a guest on this unit only
calling it we can't have you well do
absolutely we'll do it all right and
then we'll set him up with some set me
up to do so I got those DeAndre still
your peeps I'm I'm into it okay you got
it and guys thank you so much man I
don't know people know but I just want
to say out loud to your people thank you
for helping those kids every December
bro oh yeah you're good man I got a ton
of dope [ __ ] for them this yeah man
you're good dude you're good so thank
you love you man I love you guys thank
you thanks this the fine kid brow